those who know me from my work at NFL
Network or here on the Rich Eisen show
you won't know how I feel about punters
Pekka made t-shirts multiple years a few
shirts strolled in this morning wearing
one hunters at people - correct correct
you've got one here on our set we've got
one that's available for you to go get
rich eyes and [ __ ] what rich eyes in
apparel calm that still works
also for Rich Eisen show apparel calm I
talked about punters are not just people
to their weapons their weapons they
change field position they win games
we've seen it ok over and over again I
will pound on the table
well punters are now worthy of being a
subject of a children's book - doesn't
fit on a t-shirt doesn't really roll off
the tongue but it's true the middle
school rule of Thomas More stead the
middle school rules of Thomas More stead
by Shawn Jensen is available now
wherever books are sold and the punter
of the New Orleans Saints Thomas More
stead joining us here on the Rich Eisen
show right now how are you Thomas I'm
doing great rich that's a hell of an
intro it's reciate it but it's true I
was spitting truth correct yeah I don't
I don't think we need to pump up the
group too much you know we can get a
little arrogant
quickly come on an arrogant punter is
that a fact
do those exist I'm just noting that's
very cure though correct what did you
first realize Thomas that you could punt
what does that happen I mean I've always
wanted I did punt pass and kick as a
young kid okay and I played some peewee
football a little bit and I was just I
was interested in specializing whenever
they didn't even let us kick extra
points in the game so it's always been
something I've been interested in I
played soccer my whole life and you know
just kind of like some people love going
to the golf and range and hitting golf
balls I love getting out on a grass
field and punch files damn straight you
do or what is it what is McAfee call
them pissed missiles right Mac you've
got all sorts of good nicknames for a
different pun
well some of them are not suitable for
error let's be honest
fair enough you could even you could
even say piss missile is a little bit on
the haunting edge right there but I just
I don't know man I just I just love the
fact that you know what you guys do
constantly gets you know discounted but
I'm always there for you I've always
been pound in the table and in terms of
the pass and the kick
were you always better at the punt
Thomas I would say I was always better
at the font in the kick but you know
punt pass and kick is all about throwing
it right down the straight line so I was
pretty good at being precise in all
three and that's what helped me because
I never could kick it farther or higher
or throw it further and higher than some
of the people that I was competing
against it was all about being accurate
okay so tell me about this book what
what are the middle school rules of
Thomas More sted Thomas well well
basically it's it's going from me being
born through high school and a lot of
the things that I went through and the
lessons that I learned it's it's meant
to be a relatively easy read
you know the target is kind of
elementary middle school junior high age
kids and you know I just think it's
important for kids to you know realize
that even professional athletes or
people maybe that they that they look up
to have had struggles and have not felt
good about themselves or have been
bullied or different things like that
and so I think it's important that that
they know they're not alone and
hopefully they'll give them a little
confidence and conviction and make it
through whatever the different
situations that they're going through
right now so this is based on your story
this is your story it is my story yeah
it is my story
like I said it's just all the way
through high school and it was really an
enjoyable experience with Shawn Jensen
the author of going through and kind of
going through all the different stories
of how I came to be Who I am and all the
different people that supported me along
the way it's been really an enjoyable
experience doing that so Thomas Moore
sted Saints punter here on the Rich
Eisen show what what about the bullying
let's go into that because that's so
important certainly when you're talking
to kids I mean yeah when you're talking
to kids I mean I've gotten 11 I've
gotten
I've got a six when when one of them
feels like they are left out by the
group at school whether it's it whether
they legitimately have been left out for
whatever reason or they feel it and
really haven't been you know my wife or
not we have to step in you know we
always feel like we have to step in and
say something and you know I'm not
saying they're being bullied but that
may happen down the road so what what
about this because this is so crucial
for for a child's self-worth and for a
child's confidence level moving forward
Thomas yeah look I think it's all about
having support encouragement it's no
different than when a kid falls down
it's being there to help lift them back
up and encourage them on their way and
get them back on their feet it's the
same thing with that you know I don't
think bullying is necessarily always bad
to experience I think it's good to
experience because it gives you a little
bit of empathy it's one thing to be told
about something but it's another thing
to feel it and to feel a little pain and
to hurt and it helps you it helps shape
you and so I think going through some of
those things of being left out or
feeling lonely or feeling ganged up on
it's never enjoyable but I think if you
have good friends and siblings and and
parents and uncles and aunts to kind of
help you through those situations it
helps build a bit of empathy which I
think everybody in this world could
certainly use a little more of right now
and then feeling yes and we'll get to
that a little bit more in a second you
know an experience of you during a high
school football championship you missed
an extra point to tie game and
experienced I guess that is that part
that's part of this book as well yeah I
would say that was a big turning point
in my life we were in the second round
Texas 5a high school state playoffs we
were playing in the Astrodome and we
were playing against the team called
Port Arthur Memorial with a running back
that I'd never heard of named Jamaal
Charles I end up being pretty good yes
and indeed he ran for four touchdowns
against us in that game and anyways I
had a chance to tie it at the end of the
with two minutes left in the game and
missed the extra point hit the left
upright we were playing on NSL post
because we were in the ass
instead of high school so for high
school game that have been good and I
just remember after the game not wanting
to let that be an excuse and I just took
it on the chin and come took
accountability for it my whole town was
there in attendance and it was really a
difficult experience but I think just
taking accountability for it in the
moment really helped me on my path I
didn't know it at the time I mean I
didn't even think I was going to plan in
college at the time and that's kind of
one of the things I've always went on
moving forward I've always I've always
you know trying to put the
accountability on myself even if even if
it's not my accountability I've always
tried to do that because you know
excuses are for losers to me and so you
just got to you got to find a way to
always put it on your own shoulders the
middle school rules of Thomas More stead
is a book for kids and it's available
wherever they're sold by Shawn Jensen
and Thomas More said if you couple more
minutes with the Saints punter here on
the Rich Eisen show we talking about
accountability talking about what's
going on in the world and empathy boy
did this really settle into your locker
room recently Thomas what can you tell
us about the Saints locker room as it
currently stands after Drew Brees what
he had to say publicly about never
agreeing with anybody who would not
stand for the national anthem and then
saying what he said in terms of an
apology publicly and then zooming with
his you and his teammates on the subject
and then instructing the President of
the United States not to use what he had
said before as anything to divide
certainly after he has spoken to his
teammates I kind of set it all up and
I'm wondering what you could tell me is
the current state of affairs with your
locker room
well look I think pretty evident over
the past number of years that to have
the type of seasons we've had to have
lost the way we've lost in the playoffs
the past three years and they always
bounce back we've got a tremendous
amount of leadership in the locker room
and leadership consists of sometimes
dealing in conflict with teammates and
in my time there's been no leader or
greater than drew Brees
but that doesn't mean only having a
captain's patch means your that means
that you're the only leader on the team
we've got so many leaders on the team
and I think this is going to be a
blessing in disguise not only for Drew
not only for our team but for our nation
I think Drew's a man of conviction and
he just had a change of perspective
after everybody on the team we got
together and a lot of guys let him know
how exactly they felt and maybe that
hadn't been said as clearly before to
him and all I know is Drew's not going
to apologize unless he absolutely means
it he is not going to do something
because of pressure or because of his
brand he's going to do the right thing
that's all I've ever seen him do and I
just know that he's going to handle this
the right way
and I'm really excited to see what type
of moves our team makes collectively not
only in New Orleans but across the
country with all the different sports
leagues because I know somebody like
drew with the power that he has to move
the needle if he gets passionate about
something the proof will be in the
pudding and he's already told us that
his his actions will speak a lot louder
than his words and so I'm excited to see
what happens so again I know what
happens in the locker room stays there
but how would you categorize that
videoconference meeting when when Drew
was hearing from his teammates what was
extraordinarily vulnerable
it was difficult it was emotional and it
was necessary and like I said I think
it's everybody knows where everybody
stands now it's as clear as clear a
communication as it was possible and and
that's a really really positive thing
and
like I said before I'm just really
excited to see what actions take place
following what happened and I know drew
I feel like I know him really well I've
been his teammate for 11 years and I've
seen the way he's dealt with adversity
and I've seen the way when he gets his
muscle behind something and he's
motivated he's going to he's going to
make a move and so hopefully
collectively as a team we can all help
move the needle I know for myself
personally my eyes have been opened more
than ever before in the past few weeks
and I'm a little ashamed I haven't done
more or been more involved and so I'm
looking forward to being part of that as
well Thomas More said of the New Orleans
Saints again is the new book about his
life the middle school rules of Thomas
More stood available we're all books are
sold
what's the most upset you ever made Sean
Payton what's the most pissed he's ever
been Thomas oh man I've gotten that that
that glare before um he doesn't scream
as much at me when I screw up now I
think maybe it's just because I'm older
with four kids and a wife and we've got
a little more respect for me
Mary definitely a few moments as a
rookie where I got my butt chewed out
pretty good and you know I try to avoid
that I try to you know there's a lot of
a lot of funders that get a lot of
notoriety for big big long punch and I
live in a different world you know I've
just tried to be the epitome of
stability at the position for grains I
try to hit it about 48 to 50 yards every
time with hang time and I hope it's the
most boring play there's a fair catch
and we're off the field and so I think
sean has appreciated that over the years
and I'm gonna try to do that as long as
I possibly can well I'm looking up your
I'm looking up your stats here on Pro
Football Reference I don't see any pass
attempts have you tried have you have
you thrown one yet Thomas yeah we have
one fake called against the Cowboys in
2014 okay we didn't have a check out
unfortunately and they were in fact
shakes and their linebackers were
smiling at me
just looking at me before play Ranma
good feeling that is we were down 14
points with seven minutes left in the
game it wasn't exactly the the best time
to catch him off-guard and so anyways
III did like one guy miss I thought good
about that okay got tackled decided not
to throw it into coverage and Shawn came
over to me on the sidelines and and and
did apologize to me in person he perfect
for the play call and that's that was
enough for me I respected that so but
I'm still you know we did ambushed in
the first Super Bowl I keep telling
people were saving ambush 2.0 for me a
passing attempt in the second Super Bowl
that I'm in so it will have to wait for
them love it and would you care to guess
how many tackles you have in your career
Thomas I'm gonna guess I'm gonna guess
I'm credited with 11 or 12
by the way give me give me one or the
other give me one or the other give me
one of the other cuz one of them is
correct which one you got all right I'm
gonna go against my ego and say eleven
correct Tommy or stood that's a punter
you just shut off man yeah 11 one year
in 2012 you had three in a season wow
that's a lot of kickoff returns that
yeah that wasn't a good that wasn't a
good kickoff return year but hopefully
if you go through my punting staff yes
we have very few punts in the past seven
or eight punt tackles in the past seven
or eight years so I tried to like I said
have a lot of boring plays I love it
Thomas
thanks for calling in really appreciate
the time enjoyed the chat let's do it
again soon rich thank you for having me
on I really appreciate it always man
punters our guests - Thomas okay
thanks to the call that's Thomas Marston
fantastic 11 tackles in his career
impressive know the middle school rules
of Thomas More stead available wherever
books are sold
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here